turning Michael avenatti who filed that
motion for stormy Daniels joins us once
again at the table first on CBS this
morning so Michael let's discuss I've
heard this motion described as brilliant
brazen and frankly crazy so what exactly
are you looking for here well the motion
is not crazy I mean we're relying on US
Supreme Court precedent and a whole long
line of cases in the Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeal it is well founded it was well
thought out it's incredibly documented
what do you want what we want is we want
the truth I mean we want to know the
truth about what the president knew when
he knew it and what he did about it as
it relates to this agreement we're gonna
test the veracity or the truthfulness of
mr. Cohen's his attorneys statements and
we're confident Gail that when we get to
the bottom of this we're going to prove
to the American people that they have
been told a bucket of lies the motion
references a meeting on March 21st what
happened at that meeting we had a what's
called a meet and confer where both
sides confer about impending motions we
raised this motion with the other side
and I think one of the things that was
significant during that meeting was we
asked mr. harder mr. Trump's attorney
whether mr. Trump was a party to this
agreement and we heard crickets they
don't know he said they don't know yet
whether mr. Trump was a party to this
agreement how do you not know whether
you're a party to an agreement unless
you're just trying to make it up as you
go along you're essentially arguing this
is bigger than stormy Daniels now but
this essentially agreement was an effort
to influence the 2016 election what
would the judge need to be convinced of
in order to grant your request in order
to have a deposition of the president we
don't think it's a big stretch the other
side is attempting to force this case
into a private arbitration hidden from
the public where the public doesn't
learn what really happened in order for
the judge to determine that we are
arguing that under the law were entitled
to the deposition quite honestly there's
a there was a mistake by the other side
in pushing this case into federal court
and now we're going to bring it to bear
you heard Paula Reid make reference to
the statement from from the spokesman
for Michael Cohen who called this a
reckless use of the legal system but
went on to say in order to continue to
inflate Michael a vanadis deflated ego
and keep himself relevant this is a
politically motivated and people see
through this charade
mr. Schwartz is a
hack straight out of central casting
next question if the president agrees to
a deposition only but it were under seal
would you agree to that we would fight
that I can't imagine that the public
would sit for that but I mean obviously
the judge ultimately decided that we
would adhere to it you mentioned Clinton
versus Paula Jones in your motion why is
that relevant well it's the Supreme
Court precedent the Supreme Court
already decided that a sitting president
could be deposed in connection with a
civil matter and if that was the law
then it certainly has is the law now it
hasn't been overturned mm-hmm if they
came to you with a settlement in this
case would you accept it well I think we
would we would consider it we would I
would converse with my client it would
depend on the terms of the settlement
but I mean at this point I don't see how
the case gets resolved short of the
truth coming out and the whole truth for
the American people yeah you called mr.
Schwartz a hack and then then moved on
but I also think you know a lot of
people Michael are saying that you're a
hack to that this is all politically
motivated what do you say about that
this is really nothing more to attempt
to embarrass the President of the United
States it's just simply not true I'm not
involved in politics I'm representing my
client the president and mr. Cohen are
the ones that have have spread
half-truths and falsities about my
client my client wants the American
people to know the truth and nothing but
the truth and quickly when do you expect
to hear from the judge we have a hearing
set on April 30th and both sides will
argue the motion at that time and the
court will either win or a decision then
or shortly thereafter did you have any
trepidation about filing this to depose
the president United States did you have
any trepidation whatsoever none because
it's well supported by the law and we're
confident in the motion avenatti
thank you very much first we appreciate
it yes we do